let's keep it going and speak to more
people we've spoken to a number of
really interesting folks already today
let's go to why don't we go to enrique
from los angeles california the city of
angels
hello david can you hear me i can hear
you fine
great cool
well
yeah i just wanted to say that um
what's going on in ukraine it's really
sad uh it's horrible
and i really think that
um
i think that the world i think
i just don't see how putin's gonna stop
what he's doing
i think that he's crazy he's a lunatic
and that
he really yeah that i i don't see how
inevitably in the future like we don't
go to war with him i don't know it's
just pretty scary i think he's gonna
hold
the country hostage with his nukes like
he's gonna threaten to use them or he
might even use them i don't know i think
he's desperate
and it's really yeah i mean i think
you're you're correctly identifying that
putin's personality does not make him
suited to just kind of say
okay you know what you guys are right
we're gonna back off it seems as though
he needs either some negotiated off-ramp
that allows him to save face and at
least come off like maybe he kind of won
or
he's gonna go down with the ship you
know and that would be
nuke usage escalation of some other kind
i basically agree with you about the
general concept here which is putin's
not suited to just say
let's quietly end this
yeah and then again like i've said
before like
how are the
difference between republicans and
democrats
donald trump right got impeached over
that phone call with zolin with the
president of of uh ukraine right
he was toying with them he didn't want
to help them he wanted to get us out of
nato he wanted to weaken it how are they
not using this
you know what i mean
to why are they not putting it out there
trump literally was praising putin in
the beginning of his campaign hey russia
if you're listening the emails help me
blah blah blah paul manafort working for
him for free all of these things
regarding russia it's like right there
man listen we've been trying i mean it's
just you know fox isn't going to talk
about that but yeah of course it's like
trump is now taking credit for arming
ukraine when he delayed giving them
those arms because he wanted dirt on
biden but ultimately was sort of shamed
into releasing the a like we're trying
to talk about it but you're completely
right it's not becoming the predominant
story about what's happening there
yeah man it's just it's i am actually
i'm just really worried that it's a
really
nasty situation and um yeah it's hard to
imagine it ending in any way that we
would call
positive you know i think it's going to
end in in in a destructive way one way
or the other
yeah i mean and then just putin just
wants to rebuild the ussr i mean there's
no doubt about it
you know he's just like trump ego it's
all about him he's he's crazy i mean
the world doesn't want this anymore the
world is too civilized now i think and
you know i don't think even china wants
to you know reverse back to this type of
of conflicts in the war you know they
want progress they want to
you know they're i don't know this is
just really bad and i hope
i thank god biden is president i mean
can you imagine imagine if it was trump
i know i know it would be
and then fox would be defending
it would be crazy it would be crazy
my pleasure everything's good in la
uh well gas is uh horrible i have a
truck i have a i have box trucks so i
have a tiny little family business
and over the last you know we were
paying about four dollars for the diesel
like a year and a half ago yeah right
now my diesel is six something six yeah
i put gas yesterday it's just
your fuel costs are essentially up 50
percent
yeah it's it's it's i don't
it's insane like um we go to i go to
call i live near costco here
i love costco
and their gas is way cheaper right so
i've been putting gas there for a long
time and the lines are long yeah right
now even if you get there at 5 30 in the
morning when they open up the gas at
costco the line is around the corner of
the block of costco
wow it's just it's just so bad i mean
yeah it's really expensive here but
you know we got to do what we got to do
and uh
we got to support biden and hope
hopefully
this works out well now let me ask you
just one other question do you pass
along the increased cost i don't know
what you do with the trucks i don't know
if it's deliveries or whatever
to amazon's oh okay deliver for clients
yeah
so do do you pass along the increased
gas price to your customers or do you
just have to eat it
uh
the trucking industry has become really
extremely lucrative uh when covet hit it
just blew up it you know the the people
at the ports like i know all about that
stuff the truckers the brokers they're
pretty much price gouging clients um and
it's this whole thing since china is now
able to
pretty much china can people in china
can sit in offices and act like they
have companies here in the u.s
right so they are making a lot of money
so in other words like the client i have
now he start he's he's chinese born but
he was raised here in the us
he has an amazon business and he grew he
blew up he's the millionaire now so it
sounds like what you're saying if i read
between the lines is you're already
charging enough that the the gas cost is
annoying but it's not going to break you
no
i'm not because i'm a small company okay
the bigger companies since they have the
leverage and all the trucks and
everything with the ports they're price
gouging these guys and my i just did
raise my price 40 bucks per trip okay uh
but it's going to have to go up more so
yeah it is it is well but it's going to
end up in the with the consumer anyway
so we'll see what happens but all right
my friend well uh keep keep it up all
right
thanks thanks man okay you're the best
thank you take care there's enrique from
los angeles
running a trucking business a trucking
business
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video